welcome sorry we woke up to this video a
15 minute game let's see what happens I
play d4 for a change playing against
wrong rook okay let's see how he handles
rooks we have an have a ruler pass
Spanish opening just playing the main
line here is not doing for the marshal
oh now he's taking a minute okay yeah
okay let's go h3 the absolute main line
of the room that she going at least I'm
I have some experience from the black
side yeah Bishop d7 this is so sometimes
I think God the Petrosian variation it's
also recommended in known one of the
books by behind marine the Romanian
author one of the best chess book
authors okay black is probably going for
this we go ping night and b7 to see five
ok do I play g4 here or not not sure
like might play h5 it's often a good
reaction to that
yeah but I i really i really want to
pledge reform that it's really fits into
the position on h5 and I can play night
and 3 2 h2o might take em plane at age
seven now tricky ok but it will be a
complicated complicated position you
should really consider h5 year in
pre-emptive strike before I get all my
stuff set up neatly on the kingside you
can try to to play em on the queenside
only 95 85 yeah that's it seems that
this is his intention
yeah my plan is to to get a night to f5
of the slip this is often even possible
if black plays g6 just a piece sacrifice
and upcoming moves our King edge to Luke
g1 okay he's pushing down okay he can go
to be form it's not immediate threat
connected to that okay night f5 I'd like
to prepare that any top g1 anyway
young black should probably really play
before that's the only consistent follow
up
instead of King edge to I could have
played a three but it's still probably
placed before anyway it's some hard for
me to to just to keep the pawn with a
Bab rook takes rook takes takes 9 a-6
feeble he will win this back I cannot
prevent before okay he wants to maybe
put it put the bishop on a fade but ok
let's do that anyway if it takes it i
have roped g1 ready and Bishop f8 I have
a Bishop g5 ok he took it so I have the
g file open you know how this should be
this should be dangerous for black it's
not clear how I'm likes counterplay is
going to unfold it well before b3
something like that but them the Queen
site is nice but if you have mated in
the meantime it does not help okay one
thing is I cannot easily play rook g1
because II for hangs this is some
something I need to address probably by
playing Queenie to this might be a good
idea anyway as it also has a look at the
sea for porn so that after before I
might take with the Queen from me too
yeah it's possible
what could like do we can think about
his King side set up as long Bishop to
f8 might be a defense night to f8 or
clean edge a Droog g8 can also be set up
but at the moment I think you should
just play B form get something going on
the queenside okay I'm not sure about
that one it takes off some pressure from
reform okay Brooke g1s serve as the
right move anyway I need to go to the G
file would be a really strange if this
was was wrong okay how to how to proceed
him night GF could be could be a move
10d Queen h5 but a problem could be that
he just takes it it's sometimes
difficult to to breach through this this
kind of defense when um don't have a
night hmm wonder should I just pile up
on the G file like a Bishop b3 queen e 2
and then double yeah that's not it's not
bad
95 might speed up thanks though tricky
I'm not sure about the possibility of a
nice trade I think he must take it
anyway I'm he cannot tolerate the night
on g5 hmm interesting yeah i think i'm
going to do that I only hope that I only
hope that the position is some still
dynamic enough that I can still break
through only with bishops
yay must be very careful now he can
never play move like age six year I just
go back to f3 uh huh interesting okay I
was tending to go here anyway let's do
that in a way I've tried to save a tempo
here hoping that he will take on g5 so
that my bishop can be developed with
temple maybe he's avoiding that yeah
what I'm trying to say h6 is virtually
never possible because of just Knight f3
and then h6 is a welcome target okay
Queen over them it's not what is it
exactly doing you see playing no 36 know
okay I probably need to move it this
might introduce the additional IDM to
take on c5 I'm cautious it might
introduce the idea probably it's not
really great takes and d6 is the basic
technical idea to try to get the Queen
away from the f7 defense but to the 60
and can just ignore all that just go to
the seven or something and then it's not
clear what the capture really has
accomplished ok I'm not not sure what
black I should do now
trying to get more pieces to defend ok
so I'm doubling on the G file I guess
but how exactly on g3 not so easy to say
let's do that rook g4 I mean was also
interesting keeping the option of rook
age 4 but the queen is very short on
squares I really don't want to do that
yeah he pretty much gave up on the idea
to get any counter play on the queenside
he just shoved all the pieces to the
kingside to defend not really sure that
this zone should be a successful
strategy oh he's just blundering of a of
7 I can just take f7 him that's a bit of
a shame when he was interesting now this
sir I welcome of course but how exactly
do I win after that King g8 hmm yah
night age six and then Rock g1 this this
right
or back to I think this is in fact this
is quite good check why not I just saw
ever have a rather prosaic way to to win
this Queen f7 I thought
now okay I don't really want to do that
and we have seven thread squeegee eight
mate and he probably has no real move
against that maybe I bet this win he
hasn't it he has no move if he takes
Knight takes with check King g8 night XD
6 i'm just winning all the pawns let's
effect a very clean way to win check
yeah I now I have a for this is a the
important finishing touch him if he
attacks the night on d6 i'm going to
take on b5 with the night and if he
takes on a 4 i'm taking on see form and
from see for the night is protecting me
too and I'm getting a while taking him
and that's it basically i have found
black resign three extra points now and
then going to win c4 probably as well
yeah i don't think he played them this
defense a bit too to passively just
getting all the pieces to the King side
um I mean it's it's not easy to play but
still I think he should should go for
some sort of counter play this even this
move not completely out of the question
but just before something trying to try
to get something going maybe maybe this
can be an idea with this plan trying to
get the Knight to f4 and they don't
really want to take it activating the
the bishop yeah that sets a complicated
position ready
it there might be necessary for me to
take it and then this is a good movie
either super-move cannot take because of
f7 and I'm intending to play something
like this rook see one and maybe i will
get the pawn tricky position though not
not easy in fact i think that if we look
at this position maybe you should just
play Bishop f8 and go for B form I mean
there must you must do something here ma
I'm not sure night g5 not clear in fact
even here I'd like to suggest
improvements like before here maybe get
some get some counter play on the road
find it quite quite strange that stock
fish is giving a form which after a
three looks completely completely
strange why would you close the Queen
side yeah this is just a joke why does
much better here the computer gives
black is better which does not make any
sense really I have to play on the G
file and like has nothing here it's a
bit a bit strange it wants to play kha
ten g6 maybe still it looks better to
play here for just be for getting files
open should be okay I mean I haven't
just refuted this is opening for black I
just played the normal moves I think
yeah this should be some counter play
black can try to take and play 93 or at
the bright moment could play be three
it's mostly the capture though I mean
this it's not clear if it is really
leading to much the Queen site is sir
staying close to him like that now maybe
I can even play here there must be
cautious not this seller is wrong Webbie
chef does not have any square so he
needs to play something actively on the
queenside the way it went down it
already was was difficult to play okay
this is a big mistake but there were
never better moves but the White has
already made the tech rook g1
everything's on the room on the king
let's say he plays something like before
yeah rook here it takes day croupier
just just for argument's sake how is
vitam continuing yeah one possibility is
the sacrifice iam this is already tricky
Joe a long line but it's some check
check check and white is probably
winning those weaknesses are just too
too severe that's the H porn they have
porn or white is probably winning here
it's a very difficult to play for black
anyway now it is just too passive and I
have basically all pieces in the tech
all right thanks for watching